I think everyone has an origin story  that matters and that's important  so I was probably seven years old you  know I always knew I wanted to start my  own company the question was what our  mission is to stop climate change build  an impact-oriented company that made  Healthcare better changing the Plastics  industry advancing Health Equity by  making Mental Health Care radically  accessible and inclusive to improve A  Billion Lives by scaling innovations  that would change the world I was all in  when we are successful as an industry we  should put the human at the center by  being part of an ecosystem of change  makers who believe the world can be  changed  there's no single path that human  impulse to make things better  we have to radically challenge the  status quo but love compassion and the  willingness to sacrifice some of the  opportunities for the betterment of the  collective that is what it means to be a  servant leader and that is what we were  taught at Stanford